If I wanted to write comments during Hello.
Oh, look. Yeah.
Hello, everyone. Welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. This is clustered, the show where I
get to look really silly fixing broken clusters
by members of the Kubernetes community.
And before we get started, there's just a
little bit of housekeeping.
I would encourage you all to join where's
my button?
I swear I've done this before. It's been
a break. Please join the Discord channel, Rawkode.chat.
There's a 300 and something people in there
now talking all things Kubernetes and cloud native.
Come and say hello. It'd be a pleasure
to have you there. Also,
if you've not subscribed to the YouTube channel,
you should do so now. Remember to click
the bell and you will get notifications for
all future episodes of clustered and other episodes
of Rawkode live.
I will do my best to cover all
of the different technologies in the cloud native
landscape, giving us a hands on tutorial on
how to get started.
Alright. Now for cluster today, I am joined
by Mahmoud and Marcus. I almost called you
Displeak there because I was looking at your
face and your name. But thank you both
for joining me today.
Mahmoud, how are you?
Thank you. Thank you for having me. I'm
doing great. My name is Mahmoud. I also
go by Moody.
I'm very excited to be here and work
on the the the what we described as
a car crash of a cluster that Marx
has set up for us. I'm very excited
for that.
The clusters are always fun. And, Marcus, please
tell us who you are.
Yeah.
Marcus Johansen.
I work at Equinix Metal on all sorts
of integrations, Kubernetes and Terraform and SDKs,
etcetera.
And, yeah, also looking
I I looking forward is, like, not the
right set of words, but
this will be an adventure.
You're right. Definitely.
I I I totally forgot to introduce myself.
Sorry. I'm
I I work at Carta as an SRE,
and
I I'm we're hiring. If anyone's interested, please
DM me. That's it. I I just assumed
you didn't want to share with us. That
was all, you know, but no. Thank you
for that as well.
It's it's interesting that you say you're looking
forward to it and we talk about car
crashes. Like,
it's definitely the most daunting thing that I
do on a weekly basis. But at the
same time, it's weirdly
fun
and I'm hoping we we all enjoy this
today.
Okay.
Well, let's get started.
I will pop up my screen. I'm hoping
you both have access to our Teleport Clusters.
Custard number 29 on episode 13 is from
Marcus here. So
will I call you Muddy? Is that what
you prefer?
Yeah, sure. Muddy. Right. Okay, Muddy.
We're jumping into this one together. Are you
ready?
Sounds good. I'm
excited and scared at the same time.
Oh, good Firefoxes.
Oh, there we go.
My computer has been struggling today. I hope
this is not
part of episode thirteen's curse,
but I am in a session.
I will type all echo hello.
If you wanna just do the same, let
me know you're in the same session. There
we go. Perfect.
Yay.
Wonderful. Alright.
So we've got a little bit of setting
up to do. I'll do this for you
and then I will give you the honors
of running whatever command you want to check
if we have an API server.
Oh gosh.
The flow Should I should I be able
to see the should I be able to
see the session too or housekeeping?
I'm hoping you can see my screen.
I can see your screen. I can't see
the session in the list of session in
the list of active session. It's a different
cluster. You'll just need because you're the breaker,
you don't get access to the terminal. You're
Why not? Alright. To the broadcast view.
Okay.
Cool.
I guess,
should should we get started?
Yeah. Go for it. I recommend get nodes,
get pods, pick whatever one you want. It's
always good to work out if we have
an API server first before we start doing
anything else. Yeah. Oh, thanks for the alias.
Yeah. I guess we'll check. Oh, we have
we have a response. That's good. Around 01:20.4.
Awesome.
Let's check
what's going on with the nodes. Are our
nodes okay? Looks looks fine.
We can check
pods.
Alright. Let's check the default first. The default
namespace
no real pods. Let me check if there's
any
deployments, maybe.
See that the
this was scaled down. I don't know if
this is part of the puzzle, but let
let's
maybe we're
maybe there are notes here for us that
we can look at. So let me see.
Nope. No notes here.
Okay.
So
services,
ingresses.
Any ideas? David, please. Yeah. Yeah. So let
let me catch up there. I had to
refresh my screen just because there's there's a
weird bug in Teleport that's not gonna affect.
But you ran it get pods dash a.
Right? And I'm I kinda missed out there.
So what we see is this is a
pretty healthy looking cluster with the exception of
when you run get deploys,
it looks like a skilled then.
Mhmm. I I would suggest we just list
edit that deployment and check what the replicas
are set to, try and scale it back
up. I'm assuming it's not gonna be that
simple. However, we'll we'll find out. Trying to
look at Marcus's face and see if he's
laughing or sneaking or not. Yeah.
We need to we need to monitor Marcus.
So I'm gonna say one replica. Does that
sound good? Yeah. Go for it. One of
the things I love about this show is
just seeing the amount of ways that people
modify and interact with the manifest. I'm a
I'm a I'm a cube control edit kind
of person, but a lot of people like
doing like deploys and scales and stuff like
that. Yeah.
Sorry. I hope you can't hear that noise.
I I I'm in New York there's a
lot of noise outside. Hopefully you can No.
All good. Yeah.
Alright. So okay.
So
yeah. Go ahead. Sorry. I was just gonna
say your your skills are up to one
replica. We can see we have one desired
but we're we're not getting anything here.
No pods. Yeah. We've ran a replica set.
Mhmm.
Our control plane is potentially being played with
a little bit here.
I wanna look at, yeah, I wanna look
at the the deployment.
Think it's called Yeah. Plus third. Yeah. Thanks.
Alright. We just see that it's scaled. We're
not seeing any other events listed here.
Failed to create replica failure. This could be
interesting.
Yeah. Let's look at the the concern that
the break isn't the break that actually happens.
My first thought is the flags
on control
plane components. I've removed the replica set controller.
So
The flag the flag on on where? Sorry.
On the API server,
it's actually a controller of controllers.
And you can actually disable individual controllers like
the replica set controller or the pod controller.
I suspect that could potentially have been messed
with.
Let's let's look let's look at the cube
system,
actually.
Let's see if all our
what what's running in here? Etcd API server
controller manager
scheduler
core DNS. I mean, everything seems suspiciously
normal in here.
Oh, wait. I do see I do see
oh, that's the name of the cluster. Right?
This plague. That's your handle. Right? That's his
handle. Right? Time every time I see it
on screen, I'm, like, getting highlights. It's like
Slack highlights going off in my head.
I can't I
can't help but try to respond to the
screen.
Yeah.
So, David, you were saying you wanna look
at one of those controllers?
Yeah. Let let's let's go to the
the manifest directory,
and we'll see if Marcus has been kind
enough to
it doesn't look like anything's been modified, but
that doesn't really tell us anything. So
my first explanation was they should
Sorry? All those folks who go out all
those folks who go after file times like
this can be manipulated so easily. Yeah.
Yeah. I think on the cluster I broke,
I set them all to like nineteen forty
two or something like that.
Just to confuse people.
Alright. So
my gut tells me that we should be
looking on the API server here.
There is a
No.
What are we look are we looking for
honks? What are we looking for? Yeah.
Well, maybe I'm looking at the wrong one,
but there's
there's a flag you can pass to the
API server
to tell it which controller. Oh, in fact,
It's controller manager. I'm I'm being ridiculous.
Yeah. Maybe control manager. Let's see.
So what do we got here? Yeah. Here.
So this
modified controllers.
Now the star means run everything,
but you can actually do replica sets to
disable that controller, but I don't see that.
So there is my hypothesis.
The so the controller of controllers
is most likely running the
this that that specific control. They're having, like,
a set controller. Right?
So Right now, I would assume it's running.
So my next thought is we probably wanna
take a look at the logs of the
controller manager.
That's not sent to you. Okay.
Yeah. Sure.
Let's find the pod and cube system.
And I'll say logs,
tail I don't know. 100.
Oh, I have to say cube system. Sorry.
Alright. There you go.
Interesting.
Minimum CPU per container is one. Request is
500. Minimum memory usage is container is two
fifty six, but required one twenty eight.
Oh,
this okay.
This feels familiar.
I'll
say what I think is going on. It
it it might be a limit range going
on
in that namespace perhaps.
Yeah. Either the limit range has been set
of the namespace
or because of the deployment
has been modified. Yeah. I think we should
check both.
Okay. Do you wanna do one of them?
Sure.
Okay. So
I know what the manifest should look like.
So I'm gonna jump straight in
Yeah.
Into here. Alright. You're the main author. That's
right. Yeah.
Yeah. This is my my million dollar application.
So
Mark Marcus, you did you say something? Sorry.
No. I said that's just it's cheating that
he has the whole he's got, like, a
built in differ in his head.
Yeah. So I think it's probably gonna be
limit ranges. Do you wanna pull them out?
Yeah. Let's let's look at that. So limit
range.
Oh, look.
Default created on today.
Sometime today.
Okay. So let's describe it.
Limit range default.
Oops.
I got it here.
Okay. So so that's
it looks like we found the first
main
issue.
Let's see what happens. Should we turn it
off or delete it, or do you wanna
change the resources on the deployment? Either one
would work. Right?
We could just delete that limit range. That's
that's not doing us any favors.
Alright. Let's do it. So delete limit range.
I'm gonna say
you know, it's funny because I'm laughing because
I I had similar ideas when I was
thinking about the cluster the cluster that I
would break. So this is that that's awesome.
Yeah. The limit rate. And that customer I
broke, I used limit range as well because
I thought they're so esoteric. Nobody would know
to look there.
And they apparently, everybody just knows limit ranges
are a thing. So
I I guess so.
If anyone didn't know there, now you know.
Okay. So should we look at the logs
again? Because I'm not seeing the pod show
up. So Yeah. I think that's a good
idea.
Oh, I
I'm typing, but I'm not getting any feedback.
Do you mind typing it instead? Because it's
it's not typing for me. Yeah.
Danger.
Uh-oh. Okay. I'll I'll rejoin I'll refresh and
rejoin the session. Yeah. I'm gonna relook today.
Reload.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
I While while I was breaking it, my
Wi Fi, like, cut out while I was
doing it, and I worried that I had
done
something I had not intended to do.
Oh, man. I no I don't think I
have access to
Yeah. I think Teleport is down.
Marcus, did you Teleport?
I my hands are right here.
The wait. Did we did we do something
that broke teleport?
I mean, all we did was delete the
limit range. Could that have
delete
happy kind of debugger. I suspect the max
of one gig on the memory
potentially let something loose. But I didn't see
any other pods running on the system.
The the the tell was was Teleport
did it go out of memory or something?
I don't know. Something happened for sure. Should
well, let's ask Marcus. Should Teleport still be
working?
It should still be working as far as
I know. Yeah. Although it's great to watch
you, like, just, like, paint this bridge that
you're gonna drive down and
Alright. So as a backup, I've if you
wanna just jump over to my screen share,
we'll try and SSH up to the host.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sounds good. The host is
done. Oh, there we go. Okay. So
Marcus, what have you done?
It's it's How how are the other nodes?
Well,
yeah, I guess. I've got I've filled up
the portal, but, yeah, why don't I try
another node first?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Let's try the work. The
coincidence the the timing is uncanny, but Yeah.
I really don't think I I
don't think I triggered this.
Let's see. So the other so yes. Something
happened. When we deleted that limit range, there's
been a
causal event.
It feels, yeah, it feels almost like a
direct
side of The teleport's back. It's back. It's
back. Okay. Okay. Go. Go. Go. Alright.
Refreshing. Our
session is still there.
Yeah.
Let's see if the CPUs went
wild.
The API server
no. That's okay.
Load average actually hasn't changed. Okay. That that
timing is uncanny, but I think it was
Yeah.
I'm
looking at the I'm looking, yeah, I'm looking
at the
the the what's it called?
The three CPU metrics, and everything looks
looks okay.
Yeah. I I think it's fine. I think
that was
I I don't really believe in coincidences,
but it must have been a coincidence. I
mean, we can we can look at the
teleport pod and see what happened. Right? Yeah.
It's running on a host because I don't
trust people not to kill it in a
container. Oh, gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. Okay. So,
Marcus, how are we doing? Give us, like,
a a maybe a little hint.
How are we doing? Are we okay? Are
we doing good? Or No. Doing good.
Like like I said, I I
I love the paths that you're
setting
and that you're exploring. I think it's kinda
giving giving me some insight into things to
look for in your cluster.
So keep keep playing those tabs and Okay.
And take note.
Alright.
So looking at logs, it looks like we
got a pod created.
Oh, image pull
Back off. Okay. Good. Let me just pop
this terminal up so that I'll cut off
that. And,
Khalid said, just joined, what am I missing?
I'll do a quick ten second summary while
we do that.
Currently, Moody and I are working on Marcus's
cluster.
Marcus used a limit range to stop our
clustered pod from being created, which we've deleted,
and that blew up our cluster, but magically
it came back. We don't know why. We're
not gonna
yeah. Actually, if that just now.
We're now seeing an image pull back off
error on our containers, our pod.
And it looks like
we're getting a forbidden from GitHub container registry,
which is a Four
four zero three. Yeah.
So
is that well,
I'm gonna assume this is part of the
plan
and that there's probably some
like, maybe a image do we have an
image pull secret,
I guess, on this? Yeah. I think so.
Like, this is a public repository and a
public image. The only way this error I
think would happen is if someone added Docker
cred style secret for that domain, which we
don't need.
So So let's yeah. Let's take a look
at the
I guess there's two places I can think
of the deployment itself or the pod,
which actually we have up here. So let's
look. Is there an image pull
is there an image pull secret here? I
don't I'm not seeing one. If we run
a k get secrets, we'll be able to
see if there's anything
configured on the namespace.
Is there
oh, yeah. There is. There's a docker config
JSON called Kubernetes.
Kubernetes.
Yeah. Which I think is to find
hide the fact that it's
weird.
But would it be would it be here,
you think? If I say I don't know.
Yeah. Get the deployment
in YAML format. Would we hopefully see a
Kubernetes
image pull secret here?
Image pull policy.
The secret will be configured with a a
registry domain.
Do you mind if I type?
Yeah. Sorry. Go for it. Yeah. So if
we do a get Kubernetes dash o y
m o.
I really need to upgrade these clusters to
one two one and get rid of all
this in here. Am I missing it?
I'm thinking the server maybe it's in the
service account.
What do you like a like, service accounts
can have image pull secrets. Maybe
we maybe we can describe that. I don't
know. But, yeah, let's look at this first.
Bananas. There we go.
There it is. But
it was attached somehow to that service account.
Right? So can we describe the the default
service account? I don't think that's
how the oh, maybe I'm completely wrong. So
I
don't know.
I'll
I'll it just for for the exercise. Yeah.
Please. Yeah. I'm curious, Niro.
Because I thought I think the secret exists,
it gets hard. There there you go. Yeah.
I knew it. I felt it. Nice.
See? I'm learning shit. So I'm happy.
Oh my god. Marcus,
your
our
thought process is
very aligned
even though yeah. So it's that's crazy. That's
awesome.
Alright. So we should either modify that service
account to remove the pool secret.
What do you yeah. What do you do
you think yeah. Should we edit
you like to do keep still edit, so
let's do that. I I love a good
edit. Push me in Vim. I'm happy in
Vim. So
Alright. So I guess we can remove the
the no. No. The top image push secrets.
Yeah. Yeah. We could just delete those.
Okay. So now
I think if we delete the pod, it
should just
fix itself, hopefully.
Hopefully,
it's my favorite part too.
Yeah. I mean or it will take us
to the next piece of the puzzle. We'll
see.
Don't need to wait on that. Let's just
see what's happening.
We got container creating.
Creating.
Looks good.
Alright.
I think we can maybe look at the
logs if we have to, but this looks
good.
Nice. Good job. Well,
we're still missing our database container.
Oh,
so do we have a stateful set or
something? Oh, yeah.
Okay.
So I'm I'm internally fuming because I think
one of my barriers didn't go up. But
Maybe you could tell us a bit of
that when we go through the next hard
build.
I think that's the best part about cluster.
That you do all these things and then
you hope that they fall in a certain
way and then it just doesn't really work
that way.
Alright.
Do you wanna describe our Postgres and we'll
see what's happening here?
Sure.
Stateful set PostgresQL.
Nothing. I think I had nothing. Know STS
was a shorthand for Stateful set.
Oh, yeah. I I use it all the
time.
The the there was a
was it API resources that shows you these
things?
I believe. Yeah. So you can look and
you can run
kubectl API resources and see all the abbreviations
in here.
So I I just picked them up as
I go. So you'll probably find stateful yeah.
There's the stateful set one.
Nice.
Cool. So but yeah. Back to what we're
doing. I think we just need to scale
up this stateful set to I think it's
scaled down. So
let me just scale it up if that
sounds good to you.
We got
more people joining late.
This is the episode 13 curse because I
had the YouTube time wrong,
I'm afraid. But thanks for joining anyway.
And you can always catch the Maybe
it's maybe it's not maybe it's not a
curse because
that means more broken clusters, more broken things,
which is which is I guess a positive
in this context. Yeah.
I'm not seeing anything here.
Interesting.
Yeah. We got a class we got a
pod that can't terminate and we got our
stateful set which hasn't been scheduled.
Do we have a replica set for a
stateful set? Oh, no. Didn't get replica set.
This would be a part.
Oh. Oh, a little more limits.
Another limit issue. The failed quota.
Uh-huh. Default must specify limits.
Oh, this okay. So now we're oh, this
is different. So this is almost like
either
well, it's coming from the stateful set controller.
So this is the first thing I look
for is where this event is coming from.
So that means it's probably
a native Kubernetes thing
such as
pod security policy or something like that. Well,
there is this resource quotas on the namespace
that we should probably check if they exist.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay. So get resource
quota.
I've rarely had to use this
the resource quotas, but that's I'm learning. So
request dot CPU, request dot memory. So it
looks like it's
it's
I'm trying to read the complaint here. So
it's forbidden because
you must specify a limit
for each of those. I see. So we
can either specify the limit or delete the
source quota?
I'm a big fan of the sledgehammer delete
approach.
But don't don't let me gauge you.
Oh, you you wanna do it? Go for
it. Yeah. No. No. I said don't let
me lead you down a dark path. If
you don't want me to delete it, just
tell me to shut up. But if you're
happy to delete it, I think we delete
it. I
love it. I love it. Sledgehammer.
Let's do it.
Alright. Let's hope we hope that the stateful
set controller
picks this up. I might have to
scale up and down or something to trigger
it. It's not
Yeah. We may have to describe the stateful
set again.
Describe
state
stateful
set postgresql.
That's still upset. Maybe there's a retry.
It's like doing a back off kind of
thing. So maybe
yeah.
That could be a validating web controller,
maybe.
Okay. Yeah. Let's look at that.
Validating
Never, my web Configurations.
Yeah.
No. All namespaces?
No? Okay.
I'll also look at me just just so
we know. We should have done this earlier.
Just, like, so we can rule this out.
Good. So none of that. Can we look
at
pods again?
Oh, it is not.
Pending.
Pending is not normally a good thing.
Spry pod.
What is another piece of the puzzle maybe?
Oh god. Okay. So
alright. So we have
how are we on time, by the way?
I wanna make sure we're we're doing good.
Oh. We're we're good. We got we got
fifteen minutes there.
Oh, nice. Okay.
Alright.
So, obviously, Affinity, there's a taint that we're
not tolerating
that's called
master
okay. So
maybe we edit the stateful set and
either remove the that
or let's see. Maybe the nodes are tainted.
Right? So if I say get nodes,
is it show taints? Is that a flag?
I know there's a show labels,
look at that too. But maybe the labels
were edited.
Just do a get node stash o yaml
and just let it list them all straight
up.
Like that? Yeah.
And then I do like that show labels.
Yeah. It comes in handy. Oh,
go ahead. Sorry. I I like the way
you're, like, spelling out mutating webhook and configuration
as though as though that's not what you
used in yours. So
I'm on to you.
I'm not gonna answer just to keep things
suspenseful.
I'm looking for taints here. Should I just
grep or something? This is a little noisy.
It is noisy. Right. Yeah. Just why don't
we just describe one of the nodes maybe
or or do that. Yeah.
Yeah.
Tate, so I see here there's a only
the master node is it look I I'm
guessing this is the master node that has
this
thing. So we should just edit the stateful
set, I think,
and just look at what the heck is
going on with affinity
or
note selector or something like that. What's that?
Sorry.
Yeah. You're right on it. There's a note
selector for named PostgreSQL.
Yeah.
I don't remember seeing
it's like, a label like that.
But why is it try Remove it. What
Yeah. We should remove it. I I'm I'm
just really wondering something else now is why
did it say
that it that it's it can't tolerate the
the
the master. I guess it's trying it's it's
just one of the things that failed, I
guess. So it's trying to find this label.
It can't find it and it also doesn't
tolerate the master. Yeah. So I think here
the node selector is trying to play it.
Let's yeah. You're right. Let's walk it through
before we go delete it. So let's drop
it at s and run get nodes again
and then let's describe our control plane node
or show labels. Yeah. Maybe that would maybe
that shows what we need.
So yeah. So we wanna look for like
a Postgres
here.
Sorry. I too much text.
Okay. So there's no Postgres label anywhere.
Yet somehow it was complaining about the
not tolerating the master taint or something that
looked kinda like this, like mast IO slash
master.
Yeah. I expected to see a label for
the node selector to resolve to the control
plane and
that didn't happen.
That's an inter yeah. That I find that
interesting that the error is almost misleading.
Let's look at it one more time. Sorry.
So we solved that we solved that. Oh,
sorry. The pod. So
describe pod, Postgres,
l zero.
Too many s's.
Sorry.
Yeah. So That's the only clue. That's the
only hint I give.
Very generous. Thank you. So
oh, I see. So one node had a
taint
master
that the pod didn't tolerate. Three nodes didn't
match the pod. Okay. Got it. Got it.
So I only read the first part. So
it's trying to the first so the control
plane, it couldn't schedule
there because
of not tolerating that taint. I wonder if
this is like a default behavior. If your
node selector fails, does it automatically default like
the control plane because it would assume those
exist and then the taint there is causing
the weird error message.
Yeah.
So we Like, if we change the I'm
curious. If we change the node selector to
be named Moodie,
do we still get the same error? Like,
is it defaulting to that control plane? Got
it. Yeah. Yeah. Uh-oh.
Has it gone again? Think my sec my
session
oh, no.
Oh, no. Did we did we cause Teleport
to crash again? Oh, no.
Yeah. Teleport is down again.
I'm on. I I often think that this
show should be, like, sponsored by Teleport, and
then
you run into these things. And I'm like,
ah, I know why the sponsor's on here.
I don't think that Teleport is the problem
here. I think it's you, Marcus,
and you're you're
breaking of clusters.
Hopefully, it comes back again in a minute.
I really do think it's just timing.
Yeah. Do you have any rogue processes on
this machine doing nefarious activities? Is there a
Bitcoin miner on my hardware, Marcus?
There are no Bitcoin miners on your hardware.
All only only Ethereum, Cardano, and.
Yeah. The comment. I saw messing with Teleport
was a big no no. It is a
big no no. We don't we don't break
Teleport.
I think I think we're back. I think
it just came back online.
And what are all the rules again? Just
to restate them all. Like, rules and the
what the expectation is. You cannot break the
bootloader, and you must not break Teleport.
And then what what is the the goal
of the
the whole session is to have what happened?
For us to be able to modify the
cluster deployment from version one to version two
and then browse to it and see a
cloud native quote.
Okay. So let's test our theory there. We
are back. I don't know.
Did I what kind of hardware did I
throw in this? Is this just a shitty
box?
I don't know. Yeah.
Oh, yeah. At this point, we're we're investigating
to the teleport issue,
but I think we should maybe
Yeah. This box is fine. Okay. Hopefully, it
doesn't happen again.
Okay.
Let's so I had a theory and I'm
curious, but please if you've got anything better,
let's say, let's jump. Yeah. Yeah. Shoot. But
I think I wanna try editing this node
selector
to see if Oh, yeah. Still get the
same message. I'm wondering if it if it's
doing some sort of weird default policy here
where if it can't match the selector,
it just says, okay, you probably just wanna
run this on the control plane. Although I
would expect a better error message.
Yeah.
Let's take a look.
Oh, it looks oh, wait. Seventy five seconds
feels too long ago.
I'm gonna delete it.
Yeah. Sounds good.
3Period04.
The sledgehammer just keeps coming. Yeah.
I know. I have a I used to
tell a story about when I was an
SRE formerly. And like if I got paged
in the middle the night because of a
desk would fill up, I would just blow
away Varlib log and go back to sleep.
I
do like my sledgehammers.
Awesome.
Okay. So Same message. Exact
same error. So it's I guess the part
I'm looking at is the second part. Three
nodes or, I guess, worker nodes probably
didn't match the pod's node affinity. So let's
just take it out. You're yeah. Let's just
remove the node selector. Do you want me
to do that? Yeah. Go for it. Yeah.
And let's just throw it in there. Let's
make sure there's no other
scheduling
annotations of anything.
Okay. Yeah. So let's look for tolerations.
Nothing. Let's look for
affinity.
Nothing.
I think this should be it. Yeah. Let
let's test. Let's see. Edited
odds.
Come on.
Sure.
I
love how we're just killing database pods. Like,
it's like, oh, yeah. It's just a database.
Just kill it. The data's loaded in a
in a container, but we are past pending.
So
Oh, yeah. Okay. It's it's looks like we
yeah. We got past this part. Let's see
what
else is gonna come up now.
Alright. It's good.
Awesome.
Okay. Let's try and browse through our application.
I'll run a put forward locally.
Okay. I was trying to be time sensitive
too. Like, I'm wondering if I'm, like,
coming right up on a forty minute solve.
But,
yeah, as as I'm seeing things, it's like,
you know, there there was that opportunity.
There was that thing I considered doing that
I didn't do, and that would've been great
right about now.
Yeah.
I mean, did we finish do you think
we finished everything
that you wanted us to work on
that you planned? Did your evil plan work,
or did we not finish the task?
Well, I
Alright. Our application is working.
Although the video doesn't work in Firefox,
so let's confirm.
This this website broke my Chrome really hard.
Like, the the Chrome
the UI,
the the the borders the window borders on
a Mac were flickering red,
which I don't think is a thing that
you're supposed to be able to do.
It was only my only time I've ever
seen it is loading that website.
I've I've had this Chrome issue. I had
to turn off
I've I hate this bug, by the way.
It's a bug in Chrome
when accelerated graphics are turned on. If you
turn off accelerated graphics in Chrome, it might
fix the issue.
And Yeah. It's We have a fixed cluster.
Do we know that it's the right version?
How do you know if it's the right
version?
Oh,
the version of
The image? The image. Yeah.
It's a different video.
I think the text If you can't see,
it's a different thing. Come on. Work. I
I think the title on top was was
different. May your bag something something? I don't
know. Oh, yeah. That's it's just cloud native
quotes from It's a brand name. People of
the Kubernetes community that tweeted.
I mean, I can always open this in
Chrome and then my computer Just see, like,
what the running pod is. There's something
that I'm not sure if it's
if it's working as expect if it's not
working as expected.
Alright. Let's try opening Chrome. And, hopefully, my
computer doesn't fall over.
Here. If you could just check the
I'm a fan, dude, that you need proof.
I mean I need proof. I need proof.
He needs proof. No. I maybe that's I
expected something
I mean, there's still something that's
staring you in the face that's, like, you're
ignoring.
But it's it's not a problem if if
the site works, so fair enough.
Nice. Yeah. He's giving us a clue a
clue, David. He's he's trying to help us.
Yeah.
Well, I mean, if your if your perspective
is that everything is working, then everything's working.
So I I can't I can't argue with
that.
Port forward.
Running container
ET.
Okay.
Reload.
I really have to rebuild this app and
make it less shit.
Yeah. I I struggled with the video streaming
as well, but I don't know why. Yeah.
I don't I didn't I I don't expect
that I broke the video. I'm just how
do we know that this is the right
version of
of the app?
Let's yeah. Let's let's look at the
the actual deploy the pod, maybe? The pod
describe the pod and see what the heck,
yeah, that's going on. It could it could
very well be the right one, and I'm
just
I'm just
salty that things didn't go as planned.
Gonna yeah. I'm gonna describe the pod and
see.
It's saying
the image looks right. Yep. V two It
looks good.
Alright. Salty Marcus is then we Salty is.
Yes. Fixed the cluster
just in the nick of time. Good job.
Nice. So so are you gonna give us
the the debrief, Marcus?
Yeah. So, I mean, the the thing that
I thought
there there
were
the thing that I thought would have triggered
here
is the reason why you have the terminating
pod still,
and that's that there's a finalizer that I
put into the into the deployment
spec.
And
when I was when I was messing with
that earlier,
it seemed like it prevented the scaling it
prevented the scaling from working and prevented the
upgrading from working or at least that's what
appeared to happen for me. So I thought
that that would have blocked you from getting
the new pod.
I kinda thought it would have torn down
the old before starting up the new. So
I guess that's a
a scaling parameter that I could have specified,
didn't specify.
You know the position on finalizers. Like, I'm
actually offended that you even went down that
route.
Yeah. I it was just an annoyance. Purely
for deleting all finalizers and clusters. They get
on my nerves so much. Like, I understand
why they exist. They're amazing except when I
wanna do something with a sledgehammer. And then
I'm like, no. Go away finalizers.
Awesome. Yeah. I think that
Yeah. Oh, go ahead. Yep.
The
other thing that I wanted to, like, keep
the entire problem
scope, like, limited to things that a user
could shoot themselves in the foot with. I
didn't reach out to,
like, system processes or
configuration,
but it it's fun
to me to watch you, like, suspect that
it might be something more nefarious.
I I think David David's been bit too
hard. I think he's he's he's yeah. This
is PTSD right there. Yeah. After 13 episodes,
I trust no one anymore.
Alright. Awesome. Good work, Marcus. Great work fixing
that. That was awesome, Marcus. Yeah. Thank Let's
see. Now it's time to cry. Yeah. Let's
see what else we got. This is cluster
30.
Marcus, I will open a session
and
type hello.
Please let me know when you are available.
And
I will make a font a bit bigger.
Oh, I got that weird bug. I think
that means you've maybe joined.
There we go. I'm just gonna reload now
because it's annoying.
I need to reach out to teleport and
ask them to fix that because
I wonder if it's Firefox maybe I should
just start using Chrome. Anyway, let's not digress.
Let's
set up our kube config
and then work out which awful things my
mood has done to this Kubernetes cluster.
I I I'll I'll give you guys one
thing that I wanna say is that there's
a
text file in your home directory. That's all
I'm gonna say.
If anyone has seen custard before, it is
never a good saying when someone leaves you
breadcrumbs.
Good. Alright.
Nice SKR.
Alright. My NGINX pod would come up for
some reason. Can you please take a look?
Securly,
I'm at.
Alright, Marcus. Do the thing please. Do we
have a control plane?
You went for API version.
That's oh, I do have We got a
Yeah. I'm kind of and I'm, like, kinda
curious if there's anything
odd installed.
Okay.
I think these are all your standard installs.
Right?
We'll find out in all in good time,
I'm sure.
Let's try some of the basics. Yeah. There
we go. We've got our working notes.
We got
things and stuff. Okay.
It's all stuck in containers. Yeah.
And those all look like they're in bad
shape. So let's
go straight for the Podigo.
Take a look at a deployment first.
Looks good.
Let's describe where I put that clustered pod
and see if we can
get anything there.
Oh, you're gonna need the name again though.
You
have
It's like the various
forms of injecting things into the shell have
changed, so I'll just throw it into temp
where somebody else can write into it for
two seconds before I source it.
And now we can have more fun.
Hopefully.
I faint a lot of the time the
completion doesn't always work, but let's let's hope.
Oh, it doesn't have to spelling clustered. Right?
Did I? You spelled cub. Cub.
Cub? Alright. I see q. At the end,
you put cub and then hit tab instead
of cla and then tab.
Oh,
alright.
Sorry, guys. Sorry, guys. This does work. Yeah.
Yeah.
Nice.
And then I'm gonna avoid the tab complete
and try to copy paste it. Yeah. We
did defeat the purpose. Alright. We have to
find plugins c n a.
Awesome.
Great.
Let's
check our cube system namespace
and see if our
extended control plane is happy.
Yeah. Okay. Let's get pods everywhere and see
if anybody is acting unusual. Nope. Nope. Nope.
Nope.
That's a lot of broken things.
So, yeah, we don't have our cilium d
Core DNS.
Core DNS, cilium.
Who else is broken?
Take inventory. Queue proxy.
It's it's And it's pulled back up. Episode
it's episode 13,
so you can't expect anything
good. Do you know? CCM's
busted.
That'll allow b is not happy. CSI's
we're in trouble. No. I think this is
a cascading
failure. The fact that we're seeing so many
container create tells me I think that's a
byproduct of Cilium potentially being fucked. So let's
focus on Cilium first.
Maybe. Cilium deployment or is it a That's
even cycled Cilium.
And
maybe in the Cilium next phase. I think
Cilium goes in Oh, okay.
This one's cube proxy. Do we have any
hints
in here?
No. I wouldn't have thought so.
Alright.
Celeb.
Let's take a look at one of the
pods. I think we need to get
What have you done to this cluster?
Alright. Let me do a little bit of
because I'm I'm I'm just Oh, see what
yeah. Okay. I see it when I'm like
scroll wheel scrolling,
it's for my own benefit. Nobody sees me
doing that. Yeah. Yeah. You you pager.
Oh, look at that. We got our first
honky honk.
Okay.
That
at least is an easy fix.
The plot seconds.
Is there any containers?
That's the only image here.
And this is you're looking at the the
daemon set? Yeah. So is it they modify
the replica set or the pods?
Yeah. There won't be back propagation on any
of that stuff. Right?
So
oh, no. But the daemon set create doesn't
create replica sets. It's just straight up pods.
But how is the image changing from the
daemon set?
This could
if you added a container d on this.
I'm looking to see if he's laughing.
Are you familiar with that feature, Marcus? Poker
face. That's my poker face. This is I
hate it. It's the worst
option ever, but someone bit me over it
in the past. What what is it that
you're suspecting?
Okay. So container d I I was thinking
that maybe the the webhooks
that maybe he's taken us down that path
since he pretended to not be able to
spell it. You are 100% correct that we
should definitely check for mutating webhooks.
But the thing that really bothered me though
is
the daemon set hasn't been updated.
And if there was a mutating webhook, we
would still see the change here.
Right? Because this comes from the API server.
I need to satisfy my curiosity.
There's a dump config on this but I
can never remember how to do it.
Where is it?
Config.
Gonna have to go to it. Is
it container d?
Yeah. Config.
So this is the container deconfiguration.
And it allows you to see
any time someone requests this image, give them
something else instead.
And you can actually swap out the images
that way.
Oh, we should probably take a look at
this file as it exists,
but I would expect to see
something
in here.
There was no honk. Right?
Oh, there we go. There's a plugin for
honky.io.
So honk.
We will remove all honks.
I've I've actually never been to that domain,
so I don't recommend anyone to try.
It's IO, so it's gotta be tech related.
Okay. So we need to
restart.
That was one of the paths I was
gonna I was gonna register something similar to
ghcr.io.
Unicode advantage of DNS.
Yeah. No no more Unicode changes with o's
that look like o's. I'm not having it.
Done.
Alright.
Where are we? So they get pods.
I'm gonna have to roll those out, aren't
we? Do you remember the rollout command?
Or will I just go sledgehammer?
We tap our way through it.
Yeah. Go for it. I think it's
if it
rollout,
restart.
Yeah.
And then,
yeah, daemon set Cilium. Cool.
I like it when people configure tab complete.
I think that that it's my lesson for
the day.
Which one in the Solium?
Yeah.
Alright. Let's keep an eye on those pods
and see if we can get some image
pools at least.
No.
Alright. Let's describe that first one.
That's how long ago?
That's about when we did it. Right?
Let's check that container deconfig again. Is there
maybe
I can do you guys want a hint?
No, not yet. You be quiet. You little
person.
I'm
I'm not here.
Okay. If the honk's definitely gone and I
did restart container d,
maybe we need to
maybe give the kubelet a nudge.
I'll pass the pass the control over to
you. You wanna restart that? Yeah.
It says container gaze.
Okay.
Because I would expect that error to have
been fixed. And you know what? I am
just gonna go sledgehammer here. Actual sledgehammer.
The problem with the sledgehammer approach is sometimes
is you make it worse for yourself.
Image pull.
I'm assuming that's gonna give us the same
error. So
did my containerd restart not work?
Oh, the shims.
That shouldn't be a matter.
This is where my knowledge of
this is gonna be. Like, container d is
responsible for pulling the image. Right? So
this process was restarted.
I'm I'm I'm just sort of wondering if
he also played the finalizer game with those
not deleting.
Container.
They're still honking at me.
I'll Extra container d configs?
I can't remember why. I wanna tell you
guys so that you don't, like, you don't
get too stuck in this stage.
Like,
does container d run-in
one place?
Of course.
You modified every host.
That's it. All future episodes are getting one
machine.
But we only need one machine to make
it work. Right? Yeah.
That
I should have thought of that. That was
me just being silly.
I I always fall into that trap because
we're always
treating Kubernetes as this distributed thing. And then
containerd is that one thing that's like just
like the cubelet is like all over the
place. So
Yeah. I guess you would have to set
it on them all. Otherwise, it would be
an intermittent bug and that would be a
pain in the ass.
You're actually being kind with your devilishness.
Alright.
So
refrain.
I'll do it the nice way.
Hey, we have a pod initializing.
That's better.
Alright. Thanks for the heads up.
Oh, fuck off.
Alright.
Colin says
check CRI CTL logs.
It's still
honking.
Is that expected,
Amit? Yes. Yes. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Alright. Just
checking it's not just me being an idiot
with my container d restarts.
I think, Marcus, you were probably right earlier.
Will we check for mutating webhooks?
What was the other Validating, but format.
Validating webhook configurations.
But they can't actually modify the resource. So
okay.
Let's sync this one through.
I'm curious now
through whatever
mechanic
ever daemon set has been modified or there's
still something happening on the horse.
Let's check the image.
Yeah. Okay. So something's happening between
this and
the controller to run that.
And if there's no sorry.
I need go, Marcus.
No. There's a there's a dump command that
yeah. I've been trying to find ways to
just get everything, and then we just search
everything in one blast for honk.
Uh-huh. I I thought it was, a dump
a dump command.
What is it, though?
I mean, we could do get all dash
o y m o grep honk.
Yeah.
You've got a lot of honks.
Okay. So Yeah. All all all only shows
a few resource types too. I was hoping
for something that would show even more. What's
the format for the before and after?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah.
There's also
well, in GitGrep, I recently learned about dash
p, which gives you the context of the
function you're in. I'm not sure if what
that would do in YAML and if that's
supported in this one.
Alright. We need more lanes.
I don't like all this honky business.
You can also just pipe less it and
then use less to search.
Oh, net without the gripping.
Just use less for Yeah. That's right. Bet
right there. In fact, why don't you just
take over?
Thanks.
Alright. Honk one.
Cluster direct like a set.
Did we get the name letter?
I
saw that all the managed fields weren't in
a more recent Yeah. One twenty one. Using.
And this is a one twenty cluster, sadly.
It says it's clustered itself,
the clustered pod.
Are they all this?
That
do we already look at that?
Let's do the get all in this I
mean, we we've got bigger issues still. Right?
Yeah. We've got bigger issues in the cluster
pod.
Let's do a get all on the Selium
namespace and less it for honk.
That
was that was silly of me. Alright. So
there's that image.
So every image That's the best.
Every image everywhere
is the hunk image? Is that maybe what
we're getting at? So that's interesting. Something's modifying
the pod spec,
but not the daemon set spec.
Image.
Yeah. So we never actually checked that. Do
wanna describe that part? And instead of just
looking at the header, we'll see the image
as the home.
So
Yeah.
Yeah. Cool. So the image on them is
yeah. That makes sense. I don't know how
it's to get in there, but it makes
sense now.
So the demon set
what
is this magic?
There's a comment from,
Khaled who says, try another name.
Also, the fire flash says there can never
be enough honks and rick rolls.
Right.
Could the c r I c t l
logs tell us anything useful? We've that. No.
This isn't container d anymore because the pod
spec has actually modified.
Yeah. So Alright. But the d m s
has the correct one. So
I'm trying to work out.
Anything running?
Because whatever is running could be the the
instigator.
And we also know oh, no. We don't.
I was gonna say we know that
this teleport session was working, but you say
that's not managed by Kubernetes.
So this is the static manifest.
And we've got our cube controller manager here,
which has not had this timestamp reset, which
is always fun.
And I'm looking for a
So there like you can have mutate and
webhooks which are dynamic admission controllers, but we
can also have static admission controllers defined in
this file.
And I'm curious.
There's just something in here.
Yeah. Looks good. The Hulk controller.
Yeah.
Get the image. Yeah.
Sneaky.
Alright. So
I can give you guys the
the actual image
that was there before. Would that help you
guys?
Yeah. So it's kate.gcr.i0/kipcontrollermanager.
Is that right?
Yeah. It and it was version version number?
Version one one dot 20 dot four. Yeah.
Yep.
Sneaky. I I think there's a there's a
v in the tag.
There's a v at the beginning of the
version. Yeah.
Awesome.
So our controller.
There we go.
So you modified that. Yeah. Of course. Like,
so the daemon set doesn't have any other
controllers that create the pods except speaking to
the pod control. So you just modified the
controller manager to actually change the image on
all pods?
Exactly. Yeah. On the
create pod step, so there's a part that
where it creates pods. I can actually
put the code here somewhere if you if
you if you want. But it's like a
little block that basically says
replace every container's image to honky honk, basically.
So the container d alias was really just
to throw us off this the track. Right?
So so it wasn't a throw off. It
was another piece of the puzzle that I
was trying to add. So
so I was trying I was hoping that
after you do this fix that you would
have other
things to look for.
Actually,
let's see if any of them worked, but
something tells me they probably didn't.
Like, my my own
my own disruptions
don't seem to have taken effect, but I
tried a couple of things. I did the
container deconfiguration
to basically say,
instead of pulling from docker dot I o,
pull from somewhere else,
honky dot I o. And then
the other thing I tried to do was
to
do something very similar to what Marcus did,
which was to
change the service account image pull secrets,
right, so that it fails to pull the
image.
So well done, Mark Marcus on that.
One of one silly looks good.
Yeah.
The image put back also the older ones.
We need to roll out the
you know what? Can I can I just
slide time on this?
Needs a dash capital a for good measure.
That may be step two, I think. But
that should get as at least Cilium daemon
set running, the Cilium operator running, which we
also need for all of us to even
work.
It should hopefully allow us to start restarting
pods and other namespaces and not be fumbled
by the CNI plugin. But
we've no idea what else, if anything else
to expect.
That's looking healthy now. You wanna start
in a bit of digging and see what
else we've got?
So what do we what do we know
about
over ciliums are coming up. They look like
they're okay? Like Yeah. They are. They look
Alright. Let's
take a look at the clustered.
Line
line wrap is messing me up here.
Okay.
And the pods,
those
Oh, fancy.
It worked. Oh, yeah. Because the name is
different, but now I can tab complete it.
Right?
True.
And so we're still yeah. We need to
rotate these because we're still getting honky.
And you killed everything in Cilium namespace or
everywhere? Just the Cilium namespace.
I'm curious about those NGINX deployments and why
they're there. But I'm
gonna ignore them for now. It's
The user decided to create their own NGINX
deployments.
I don't really believe it's NGINX. I think
that's
maybe that's my cynicism coming through. Maybe it's
just NGINX. Maybe you just really wanted the
hello world NGINX thing running on my cluster.
That's fine.
So what did I get pods show? Anything?
I was just looking for those finalizers because
those deletes didn't go through there. What
did the get pods show? Yeah. Just get
pods. That's vanilla. Yeah.
Let's get rid of that.
Okay. Good.
That looks a little too good.
Alright. Let's do the test. Let me port
forward.
You got it?
Or
do we need to check something about the
NGINX app as opposed to the cluster app?
The NGINX is is not mine. I'm gonna
ignore it for now.
I am gonna do a port forward to
our cluster pod though.
Looks like it's spinning, which would tell me
we probably got a
failure to reach the database.
Yeah. We don't need to wait for that.
So either yeah. I'm assuming core DNS probably
needs to restart it. Right? Do wanna do
a check gib system or something?
Yeah.
Yeah. We're still got a carnage in here.
I'll let you decide the best way to
get all those pods running again.
How long how long do you have?
Don't
don't try this at home, yeah, for the
audience. Never I mean, this this will recover.
It will recover. Yeah. You're right. That's that's
the point.
But not something we recommend running in the
real world.
Probably a bad idea.
Oh, look at that. Kevin's just signed up
to be on the show.
There you go. He's got some naughty ideas
he wants to try.
I'll reach out to you afterwards, mate.
Is
does that help our port forward at all?
I would suspect.
Or maybe I hope. Not sure what the
right word is there, but
yeah. We got our app.
So we should try and update to v
two.
Yeah. Does does import forward go through Q
proxy,
I think? Yeah.
Well, no.
Or does it?
Always forget. Yeah. Oh, sure.
Yeah. The networking state of Kubernetes is where
I've been completely ignorant my entire Kubernetes career.
It's just that other people deal with that.
I don't know the the fancy command to
upgrade the v one to the v two.
So I'm just gonna do it the dumb
way.
We're going to two? Yep.
Looks alright.
They're creating.
I mean, that's to hopefully just pulling the
image.
Big is this image?
It's just a rust bainery.
Although it does have an m p four
in it with dot move, whatever it is
with the
the thing, but it's not too big.
That seems unusual.
Yeah. It does seem unusual.
I'm looking at your moody.
Well, I I I this is unexpected, so
I'll do that.
It should yeah. I think this is this
is probably more g GitHub GitHub thing than
yep.
Or is it, actually?
Yeah. I don't know if the simple way
to pull images just to test that
that we could do that. I don't know
if we I've never done that with CryoController
or anything. All images.
That is gonna list them.
Oh, wait. That was the first one. I'm
looking at these clusters.
So
pull the
r.
I couldn't figure out how to use, like,
CRI CTL to run an image.
It seemed like to do so, you need
to set up a a manifest.
Like, you have you you need, like, a
at least, like, a five line YAML,
and I just I couldn't accept that. Was
looking for ways to run it. I read
the answers. There we go. I ran into
this. Yeah. You need the runtime endpoint to
be the Oh, yeah. Yeah. The run socket
thing. Yeah. The container d socket, I think.
Yeah.
I don't know why it's not the default.
I always wondered that. Yeah.
Oh, is it slash run? I think it's
slash run.
There we go. I just missed a I
just missed a container d. Correct. Yeah. Yeah.
Nice.
I think it's run time endpoint.
I don't know if we should be seeing
any progress.
Unless we Okay.
I mean, that should be fast. Yeah. Okay.
So maybe it's just okay. Some something wrong
with
DNS networking.
Dig
at
google.com.
I'm using Cloudflare to do Google.
That made me laugh at least.
I don't think
we've got DNS.
There's a debug flag that we could try
in that c r c q.
Awesome.
Holy.
I don't know if it's just pulling in
slowly or
I'm gonna try it locally. Let's let's try
it. Maybe it's
image. Maybe we could try an entirely different
image.
Oh, no. It pulled.
There we go. Oh, it pulled. It's just
maybe just low. Yeah.
That's it. It worked.
Yeah.
Good job, guys.
So yeah. Is there anything else? I
think you did.
There was one more thing.
I think that I mean, it's so subtle.
I didn't think you guys would notice, but
there is a in the container deconfiguration,
there was a
a platform
field where I put ARM 64
hoping that it would only pull ARM 64
man or images, met manifests so
that so that what would happen is you
would find other unexpected issues in the process
itself because
the ARM 64 version of NGINX, for example,
would have completely different behavior on an AMD
sixty four
platform. But, yeah, that I couldn't get that
to work. So if anybody knows, I would
love to get some input. But yeah.
Alright. Awesome. Great breaks, both of you. Great
fixing to
terrible. They were terrible breaks. Nobody
should have to ever deal with these problems.
I don't know why everything is so, like,
happy. You know? But these things do happen
though. Right? Like, misconfiguration
is is definitely entirely possible.
I mean, I'm not sure I'd ever end
up with a honky controller manager. That was
a nice touch. But
I did not expect you guys to go
that route at all. That was that was
unexpected, like, trying to debug Cilium first. It
made sense, but it was never part of
the plan.
But I can see how that ended up
that way. The idea was to kind of
scatter
everything so that you kind of figure out
what the root cause is. So it kind
of hopefully, you guys have enjoyed it. Yeah.
Yeah. Running get pods all and seeing a
literal clusterfuck on every pod was not something
I expected to see.
Yeah. So where where is the code for
your controller at?
It's it's I can I don't know if
I can
can I share screen? Maybe I can You
can. Yeah. If you want.
Okay. Let me see if I can I'm
curious about, like, the exclusions that that you
had to bake into it.
Yeah. Here. Let me try this share screen
window.
This guy. Does that work? Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
So if you guys can see in the
Kubernetes project under package controller
control controller utils,
there is a function called create pods.
You can guess what that does. It basically
creates pods
for any
con
controller that's inside the controller managers. For example,
the daemon set con the daemon set controller,
the replica set controller, the deployment controller, the
stateful set controller, they all basically call
they all basically call this function. Yeah. Sorry.
So, yeah, I I just you can kind
of read this four five liner. That's
exactly what what I did. Yeah.
Awesome.
It would have been interesting if there was,
like, an init container, and we would have
seen we would have noticed that, yeah, it
didn't pick up that.
I I
I was thinking about ways to use a
an init container for mine to
to just
cause extra havoc, but didn't in in this
case, that would have maybe
well, I don't know if they would have
pointed us in a better direction. Having having
the hunky controller manager,
let's say, in retrospect, it seems like that's
the only way that could have been done.
Yeah. Yeah. The the you like, the part
where you you you look at the deployment,
you're like, that I that should be the
image that gets gets created and it's not.
Right? Like, so
that was the main clue or or puzzle.
Yeah.
Awesome. Well, thank you both. Two very different
breaks there. We got the nuclear approach
from Moody. We got the death by a
thousand cuts by Marcus.
Both very interesting to text. Thank you both
for joining me. It was a real pleasure.
I had a lot of fun with these
clusters.
And hopefully, the cluster 13 curse will not
follow us into future episodes.
Alright. Well, that's us for today. Thank you
for taking the time out joining me. If
you're watching and you wanna take part in
clustered, reach out to me in the Discord
or on Twitter. We're always looking for new
people and new breaks and new fixers.
And it'll be a pleasure to have you
all.
Okay.
Have a great evening, afternoon.
Yeah. Afternoon, I guess, for you both. Thank
you very much. I'll speak to you all
soon. Take Friday off. Cheers. Bye.
Bye.